belarus ukraine and moldova were
recognized as remains of the muscles
domain the politicians were able to
produce sluggers of the continents with
no dividing lines while at the same time
they did institute quite precisely the
new border lines in europe ever since
that time the management plan for the
wild central european plains is
implemented with a degree of efficiency
at least formally in 99 the Czech
Republic Poland and Hungary as I
mentioned above became part of the NATO
lines while in 92 the practice time it
took the decision to offer membership to
Lithuania Latvia Estonia Romania
Bulgaria soraka and slovenia as of
spring 19-4 on the other from 10
countries concluded accession
negotiations with the UN will acquire
membership on may first although not
included among them among the 10 romania
and bulgaria were promised membership
around the years 2007-2009 in other the
Balkan states the inheritors of the
former Yugoslavia were offered a special
track for joining the you although some
problems will have to be faced in
bringing Bosnia and Herzegovina el
pasado to meet the standards
nevertheless it seems probable that
around at the year 2010 the European
border will run along the eastern
borders of Finland Estonia Latvia
Lithuania Poland Slovakia and Romania
thus the NATO you joint venture will
have the whole continent on its side
with the exception of the former Soviet
Union stripe only on the Baltic States
Ukraine is and will remain on the other
side for time being the border line is
not and will not be a new Iron
accountant at least we don't want it
although it will be in the interest of
all those on the western side to foster
defense from Eastern as the Arctic or
perhaps rather must
in spite behavior beating economic
political or social rhian we must assure
that the border line allows for freedom
of context it at the same time giving
protection from eastern corruption mafia
blurry political activities etc our own
problems deeply rooted in the post
committed communists cows are quite
enough to deal with several days ago the
experts of the European Commission
declared the opponent is probably
prepared with the border infrastructure
to assume its duties as of May first
that means and what over every 20 25
kilometers high quality electronic
surveillance equipment computerized data
gathering professional border guards and
duty officers etc nevertheless in Poland
will fear that joining the Schengen
Agreement meant then made dangerously be
delayed I say these words with a degree
of entity as accession to the EU with
all its disagreeable aspects offers the
advantages perspective of being formerly
a part of the Schengen tighter border
security system the source of
aforementioned threats against which we
sit protection is not so much Ukraine
they originate for other further east
the border on the book river with the
help of Ukrainian authorities may become
quite similar to the present day border
on the other river being open to friends
and impassable for destructive elements
in return Poland may undertake to
support Ukraine in organizing border
infrastructure in the east as of my
first Poland will be part of the
above-described Europe we shall join the
European family as President Chirac
refers though and paradoxically we
ourselves be facing the threat of
political isolation the endeavor with
the dispute over the new constitutional
treaty is known only too well neither
was our firm stand on support for the
America
operation in Iraq met with two warm
response across Europe for quite some
time for quite some time now the Germans
proceed with their traditional policy
towards Russia disregarding that which
lies between Berlin and muscle and the
Russians are only too happy to carry
through to follow our small neighbors
prefer the policy of conciliation to
that of confrontation as far of the
European contributors are concerned and
perhaps rightly so as the accounts left
for the small countries are nevertheless
relatively significant the comms left
for torrent will not change our
condition in any dramatic degree Polish
relations with Germany are rather
strained those with Czech Republic